American feminism has been a blight on
the Grassroots feminist movement across
Europe and the way I would describe it
and I know many American feminists or
feminist based in North America that do
not fit this bill at all but they talk
about the glass ceiling they don't talk
about the basement they don't talk about
the women in the basement as the ones
that need the most liberating and I
don't mean that we going to save them
but I mean Liberation from the
constraints of their lives I mean they
don't have an opportunity to leave a
violent relationship they don't have an
opportunity to go for an abortion or to
even complain about rape these women are
just seen as disposable and then on the
other hand you've got some Elite
American feminists some of them within
Academia within very wealthy human
rights organizations where they are
concerned about somebody earning three4
of a million dollars as opposed to a
million dollars which her male
counterpart is